[Musique]
tout commence à l'au des temps quand les
hommes rendent un culte à des êtres
surnaturels qu'ils appellent
divinité les écrits Sumériens citent des
centaines de ces divinités venu du ciel
il y a 400000 ans pour s'installer en
[Musique]
Mésopotamie d'apparence humanoïde de
grande taille et très avanc
technologiquement ces êtres appelés
Anunaki se querellent et se font la
guerre s'épousent entre frères et sœurs
et ont des
enfants ils sont mortels mais leur
espérance de vie correspond à des
milliers d'années
terrestres les plus importants d'entre
eux sont le roi Anu et ses fils enlille
et
Enki
les anunakis cherchent l'or pour le
nébuliser dans l'atmosphère de leur
planète Nibiru et former une couche qui
la
réchauffera mais alors qu'il trouvent
l'or en abondance au Zimbabwé leur
troupe refusent de travailler dans les
mines Enki convainc son frère Lille chef
de la mission terrestre qu'en améliorant
un primate africain le problème de la
main d'œuvre sera
résolu ainsi il y a 300000 ans les
Anunaki combine génétiquement leur ADN
avec l'ADN d'une femelle
d'homoérectus et celle-ci génère le
premier homme l'homo sapiens un hybride
stérile mâle créé à l'image des anunakis
apte à comprendre les ordres et à
creuser la
terre les
Anunaki manœuvr génétiquement des
animaux les rendant
domestiques manipule l'épôtre sauvage
qui devient le blé et modifie bien
d'autres choses afin d'obtenir un
système optimal dans leur champ
de
l'Eden pour les travaux d'agriculture et
d'élevage dans l'Eden les Anunaki
améliorent des Homo sapiens qu'ils
appellent
Adam et pour les excavations en Afrique
il cloneent des hommes simples qui n'ont
qu'à travailler pour être jeté après
usage
lassé de cloner s cesse les Anunaki
rendent l'homme fertile et fabrique la
[Musique]
femme mais supprime génétiquement les
génom qui produisent les griffes et les
poils afin qu'il n'ai pas de
défense puis il développe les génome de
leurs cheveux afin qu'il poussent en
continu cela est inédit et complique la
survie dans la nature mais les cheveux
des femmes excitent les anounakis qui
abusent d'elle et trouvent ainsi un
exutoire
sexuel les religions imposent d'ailleurs
toujours aux femmes de se couvrir la
tête pour ne pas provoquer le désir des
dieu en effet ne les voyant jamais mour
les humains croient les anunakis
immortels et les adorent comme des
dieux cependant ces dieux se comportent
comme des bergers qui imposent leurs
ordres par le
[Musique]
bâton ainsi sous la menace de châtiment
divin naî la religion un système
d'obéissance très efficace qui perdure
de nos jours
comme l'organisme des Anunaki n'est pas
approprié à l'air terrestre il calment
leur étouffement par inhalation des
endorphine contenu dans la fumée de la
graisse
brûlée préférant vivre en altitude ils
se cachent dans les montagnes se font
représentés par les adans et édifient de
de haute construction que les hommes
doivent gravir pour les rencontrer et
prendre les
ordres en lil chef de la mission
terrestre craint toujours l'intelligence
des
humains il les chasse de l'edden quand
il s'intéresse de trop près au
laboratoire de
recherche et provoque même un grand
déluge no
re vivant à l'exception des Anunaki qui
se sauv et observ le désastre depuis
leur vaisseaux
spatiaux
mais a averti
l'ADRA et celui-ci a construit une arche
pour sauvegarder le patrimoine génétique
de sa famille des animaux et des plantes
créées pour
l'Eden
quand le déluge s'achève il ne reste que
quelques humains échappés sur les
montagnes et les Adam de zwisoudra qui
se mélangent entre eux et repeuple la
[Musique]
terre c'est alors que les Anunaki
décident d'atterrir et de se partager le
monde
[Musique]
les anunakis s'unissent aux femmes afin
de générer des chefs du peuple à qui
s'adresser pour donner des ordres et
naissent ainsi les rois
héros des mortel au pouvoir surnaturel
ancêtres des actuels souverains de ce
[Musique]
monde le plus célèbre d'entre eux Gill
gamèche ambitionne même
l'immortalité mais cela n'est possible
que sur nibirue où le mouvement autour
du soleil donne d'autres paramètres du
[Musique]
temps le roi Anu commence la
colonisation de la terre attribuant le
centre de la Mésopotamie à marduc le
puissant F
Denki mais marduc ambitionne un
empire il fondent Babylone arme ses
hommes et à bord de sa machine
destructrice il les conduit jusqu'au
[Musique]
Nil les anciens écrits égyptiens citent
ces puissants dieux géant au pouvoir
surnaturel les plus importants de ces
dieux sont MUC appelé r dieu du
soleil son fils tot dieu du savoir et
Osiris dieu des âmes assassiné par son
frère 7 le dieu du
[Musique]
mal quand marduc rentre en Égypte il
sait bien que ce territoire est attribué
à sa tante la Vierge nette fille
favorite du
Anu comme il veut remplacer Anu au
pouvoir marduc attaque sans scrupule net
jusqu'aux
pyramides
l'anunaki baisse AK qui a été attribué
le Soudan profite alors de ce
conflit il envahit l'Égypte repoussant
marduc à Babylone et net en
Grèce mais la Grèce est déjà attribué au
frère du roi Anu l'irracible dieu
Poséidon et celui-ci ne veut pas d'intu
fut-elle sa nièce
net en faveur de net appelé Athéna par
les Grecs interviennent alors le roi Anu
lui-même le dieu égyptien tot appelé
hermè par les
Grecs et le Dieu de
[Musique]
Apollon Athéa s'installe alors dans la
plaine d'atique fonde la première
Athène la protège des incursions des
Peuples de la mer et repousse les
attaques du dieu
[Musique]
Mazda le roi Anu appelé Zeus par les
Grecs ne peut repartir que quand Nibiru
s'approche à nouveau de la
terre il s'installe alors sur le mont
Olympe pas loin de sa fille bien-aimée
Athéna et profite des beautés de la
Grèce surtout des femmes
[Musique]
grecques Zeus est aussi un juge sévère
quand prometé vole savoir pour le donner
aux hommes zeuse le punit férocement et
châti l'humanité par l'intermédiaire de
[Musique]
Pandor Pandore est bellissime mais elle
ouvre la jar qui garde les mauxs du
monde et ceuxci se propage partout
condamnant le genre humain à la
souffrance non encore satisfait Zeus
provoque un déluge noyant tout être
vivant sauf un homme et une femme qui
repeupleront le
[Musique]
monde Homer et éod citent ces dieux à la
peau laiteuse les Théos qui vivent sur
le mont Olympe et ordonne des sacrifices
d'animaux pour inhaler la fumée de la
graisse brûl
le sud de la Mésopotamie où réside déjà
la famille du sumérien Abraham est
attribué à l'éohim El Shada les Anunaki
sont appelés Elohim par les
Hébreux el Shadaï donne à ses fils
camoch et Miron les familles des deux
frères
d'Abraham et à son autre fils Yahé il
donne la famille des descendants
d'Abraham les Hébreux dont le chef Jacob
est décrit comme un homme
fourbe yah est un jeune militaire qui
ambitionne d'agrandir le territoire
reçu son épouse
achera nourrit les Hébreux par de
grandes quantités de pain et lui les
entraîne au
combat quand ils sont prêt il ordonne à
Jacob qu'il renomme Israël le massacre
des familles voisines en commençant par
les femmes et les
[Musique]
enfants avec yah on ne plaisante pas
comme tout anounaki il se saoule avec du
chakar et se calme au fumé de la graisse
brûlée d'un bébé et il tue quiconque le
contredit soutenu par marduc yavé
bombarde les villes de Sodome et de
gomor qui refuse de trahir les Élohim
belzébut et Belphégor ses
adversaires c'est encore yavé qui
conseille à marduc de différencier
génétiquement la langue des constructeur
de la tour de
Babel ayant copié les techniques
Anunaki des hommes géniaux avaient
construit un missile dissimulé à
l'intérieur de la tour et souhaitaent
rejoindre Nibiru là où la vie dure des
milliers
[Musique]
d'années quand les Babyloniens
remplacent les Sumériens de ce peuple ne
reste que les Hébreux de Jacob que Yahé
a fait se déplacer en leur promettant la
terre de
Canaan depuis l'épisode de Sodome et de
Gomore craignant pour sa propre sécurité
Yahé n'utilise plus ses armes
destructrices les Hébreux combattent
donc tout seul mais leur puissants
voisins surtout les Égyptiens les
réduisent souvent en
[Musique]
esclavage alors Yav organise la fuite
des Hébreux de
l'Égypte il instruit Moïse afin qu'il
vole le pharaon et qu'avec ce butin il
pai des mercenaires pour entraîner dans
le désert une génération de guerriers
Hébreux puis il donne à Moïse des
centaines d'ordres afin qu'il se
débrouille tout seul sans l'appeler en
[Musique]
vain fort de cette armée les Hébreux
massacrent les peuples qu'ils
rencontrent sur leur passage arrivent
dans le pays de Canaan et fondent
[Musique]
Israël voulant atteindre au prestige des
Grecs qui ont les livres d'Homer les
Hébreux écrivent l'histoire de leur
pacte avec l'élohim Yahé et racontent
leur péripéties pour rejoindre la terre
[Musique]
promise pour se faire il s'inspire des
textes sumériens citant ainsi des dieux
qui créent
l'homme possède des armes
destructives et se calme en inlalant la
graisse d'animal
[Musique]
brûlé l'ensemble de ces textes la Bible
hébraïque cite aussi les malakim des
messagers divins identiques à l'homme et
dangereux pour les femmes aux cheveux
[Musique]
longs en Asie la vallée de l'Indus a été
attribué à la déesse
innana
innana est très belle son passé en
Mésopotamie l'a rendu déesse de
l'amour quand innana arrive au fleuve
Indus les natifs l'appellent ichtar et
la vénère avec ses compagnons géants qui
March de façon bizarre laissant
d'étranges empreintes au
sol
[Musique]
sous ichtar un système matriarcal est
établi la vie dans la vallée de l'Indus
se déroule pacifiquement et la pensée
des humains est tournée vers la
[Musique]
réflexion en Europe le prince charmant
Rama rej possessions à lui
attribué mais les hommes de sa suite
n'apprécient pas le grand
froid alors Rama repart avec sa cour de
Dieu et d'humain parcourant le monde en
quête d'un territoire où
[Musique]
régné quand ils arrivent en Inde le dieu
Brah à qui a été attribué le nord de
l'Inde les laisse faire
[Musique]
Rama renommé vichnu fonde alors la
culture
indo-européenne dont le langage le
sanscrit est un mélange de langues
européennes héritage de ceux qui l'ont
suivi c'est en sanscrit qu'est écrit le
Veda un ensemble de textes scientifiques
citant des vaisseaux spatiaux appelés
VI des armes à énergie des batailles
livrées en plein ciel et des
bombardements sur les
[Musique]
villes ce voisinage inattendu de Rama
dérange le dieu de la destruction Shiva
maître du sud de
[Musique]
l'Inde les trois dieux s'accordent enfin
et forment le Trimurti de
l'hindouisme mais une nuit les guerriers
noirs de Shiva attaquent en force les
Indo européen et les repousse hors de
l'Inde Brah comme d'habitude ne s'en
mêle pas chez lui les hommes sont tous
des
dieux cependant quand ils abusent de
leur divinité Brah les châtit en leur
pouvoir divin là où ils ne le trouveront
jamais dans leur jeu
intérieur ainsi les hommes explorent-ils
la terre les mers et le ciel sans jamais
parvenir à la divinité qui est pourtant
au fond de
même Rama dirige les Indo-Européens à
travers désert et montagnes jusqu'en
Anatolie où où ils sont bien accueillis
par l'ay enroit à la Turquie le Dieu
créateur
tangri Rama s'installe sur le mont argé
mais son frère virakocha en décide
autrement suivi par ses fidèles
virakocha traverse l'Asie passe le
détroit de Bering longe la côte
pacifique et arrive sur la Cordilière
des Andes là où l'air est bon pour les
anounakis les natifs des montagnes
zandines vénèrent comme des dieux ses
nouveaux arrivants ils appellent
virakocha tonatu le dieu soleil et le
représente lui et les dieux de sa suite
comme des astronautes utilisant commande
leviers casques et véhicules volants qui
atterrissent et décollent probablement
sur les pistes de
NASC les écritur bolivienne cite la
déesse
pasachamama grand-mère de la terre qui à
bord de son vaisseau spatial atterrit
près du lac titiaka génère 70 fil et
repart dans le
[Musique]
ciel
des machines resplendissantes qui
descendent du ciel arrivent à l'Himalaya
où les écritures tibétaines décrivent
les pilotes comme des dieux
volants d'autres machines volantes
débarquent au Japon le dieu empereur
Jinmu doté d'un miroir magique lui
permettant d'observer les îles du
Pacifique
ginmu fonde le
shintoïisme une religion polythéiste
prôant l'harmonie et l'hygiène du
[Musique]
corps en Chine à cette
époque les hommes sont vêtus de peau ils
se nourrissent à la façon des animaux et
vivent sans règles et sans
[Musique]
morale une légende raconte qu'un jour
une jeune fille découvrant une empreinte
de géant y posa son pied et qu'ainsi
elle engendra le dieu héros fuxie et sa
sœur la déesse
[Musique]
Nuva ils sont représentés par un buste
d'être humain et des corps de serpents
qui se tressent entre eux comme les
colonnes de
[Musique]
l'ADN Fuxi est un dieu
éducateur pour que les Chinois
deviennent des hommes civilisés fuxie
invente l'écriture chinoise formule les
règles moral et à bord de sa machine
volante ressemblant à une tortue il
parcourt la Chine prôant l'Union des
tribus chinoises sous un même symbole le
dragon mais Fuxi et sa sœur ne sont pas
seuls le dieu
wangi appelé l'Empereur Jaune soumet les
ethnies qui occupent le nord de la Chine
et fixe sa capitale près de
Pékin
le dieu yandi appelé l'empereur rouge
occupe le nord-ouest de la
Chine tandis que chiou le Dieu ancêtre
des coréens se limite à contenir ses
belliqueux
[Musique]
voisins l'ancienne littérature chinoise
décrit ses dieux comme des guerriers
géants qui se querellent entre eux
s'épousent entre frères et sœurs et se
calme en inlalant la fumée de la graisse
qui entoure l'intestin des victimes
[Musique]
brûlées d'autres dieux volants arrivent
en Australie où les aboriggènes les
appellent les frères de la foudre et les
représentent comme des
astronautes en Scandinavie les
ayantrooit sont les os ancêtres des
Vikings ces dieux géants font partie de
la cour de
Rama à la fin de la grande glaciation il
quitent l'Anatolie et s'instalent dans
leurs possessions
européennes
Odin leur chef dieu du savoir et de la
guerre est suivi par son fils Thor qui
est le plus fort des dieux et par
d'autres
[Musique]
divinités d'autres dieux encore
provenant de la cour de Rama reviennent
en Europe ces géants sont les tuat des
dananes et fond de la culture
celtique leur roi est Lug dieu suprême
la compagne DS mère
Brigitte le dieu du tonnerner
Taranis le dieu d'druide
Sucellos le dieu de la magie Ogmios et
d'autres
[Musique]
encore en 600 avant Jésus-Christ de
nouveau système de pensé apparaisse
simultanément remplaçant la religion par
la
[Musique]
philosophie au Népal Boudha pressent que
l'homme est un esprit éternel qui vit
différentes
étapes en Inde le jaïnisme prêche
également la réincarnation et
l'illumination en Chine laotse prêche le
Tao l'équilibre parfait qui soutient
l'univers mais Confucius refuse de
croire aux arguments
[Musique]
surnaturels en Grèce Socrate Aristote et
Épicure refusent eux aussi le surnaturel
et expliquent le monde par l'action de
loi
naturel cela n'empêche pas Athéna devenu
déess de la guerre de dominer
militairement
léger mais les conflitsus entre Athène
et spare affaiblissent la Grèce qui est
alors envahie par Alexandre le Grand et
le sera plus tard par les
[Musique]
Romains à cette époque les hommes se
sont multipliés hors de proportion
il est difficile de les
contrôler les dieux bien qu'équipés
d'armes mortel ne sont que quelques
centaines et ne disposent que d'un
pouvoir
technique athénna comprend la situation
et
s'adapte préférant le caractère guerrier
des Romains à la philosophie grecque
elle déplace ses intérêts vers la
prometteuse Rome nouveau centre du
pouvoir
athéna est alors appelé Minerve par les
Romains ze devient
Jupiter Poséidon devient Neptune et
ainsi de
[Musique]
suite l'ancienne littérature romaine
décrit ses dieux comme des géants
belliqueux qui se calme en inhalant la
fumée de la graisse d'animaux brûlés
l'Empire romain domine les nations qui
entourent la Méditerranée y compris
Israël où la Vierge Marie est visitée
par l'archange Gabriel et enfante
Josué Josué désormais appelé Jésus par
la combinaison des deux noms Josué et
Zeus afin d'en faire ressortir le
caractère divin est génétiquement généré
pour accomplir une mission ordonnée par
Yahé l'élohim des
Hébreux il doit chasser les Romains hors
[Musique]
d'Israël la conduite bienveillante de
Jésus n'étant pas conforme aux ordres la
rébellion juive échoue et yah
l'abandonne au
[Musique]
romains mais Jésus se sauve il est
enlevé vivant de la croix et porté au
ciel sur un vaisseau
[Musique]
spatial l'historien hébreu Flavius
Joseph éc que quand les Romains
détruisent Jérusalem en réponse à cette
rébellion les divinités la quittent sur
de grands chars céleste et tacit affirme
qu'il y eu des batailles dans le
ciel l'élohim Yahé disparaît à tout
jamais d'Israël et les Romains renforte
leur
[Musique]
occupation
c'est alors qu'un juif romain Paul pour
démontrer sa propre thèse religieuse
manipule la Bible hébraïque et invente
que Yahé est le Dieu unique créateur de
l'univers et de
l'homme et que Jésus est le Fils de
Yahvé envoyé sur la terre pour libérer
les hommes du péché
originel mais la Bible hébraïque ne
parle d'aucun péché ni de Yahvé en tant
que Dieu
créateur de plus affirmer qu'un homme
est fils de Dieu est blasphématoire pour
les
[Musique]
Hébreux le christianisme s'impose tout
de même dans l'Empire romain et la Bible
hébraïque remanié jointe au texte citant
la vie de Jésus compose la la Bible
chrétienne les chrétiens se divisent
bientôt et entrent en conflit sur la
question de la divinité de
Jésus jusqu'en l'an 300 quand le concile
de niissé établit que Jésus est Dieu et
Fils de Dieu et que le pontif de la
religion chrétienne est l'empereur
romain réunissant ainsi l'État et la
religion sous un seul
pouvoir depuis l'église catholique de
Rome héritière du christianisme de Paul
cache la Bible originelle pour que
personne ne sache qu'elle ne parle pas
de Dieu mais
d'extraterrestre les autres religions en
font tout autant elles ne reconnaissent
pas la véracité des écrits originel et
leurs livres sacrés n'en sont donc que
des réécritures
frauduleuses comment les anciens
écrivains s'y éparpillé aux quatre coins
du monde aurait-il pu inventer des êtres
et des faits s'y ressemblant entre
eux parmi des milliards de planètes il
est impensable que la vie ne soit
apparue que sur la
terre il est donc possible que des êtres
surnaturels arrivent chez nous pour la
même raison que nous allons dans
[Musique]
l'espace c'est un être surnaturel
l'archange Gabriel qui rend visite à
mahomé en
Arabie cet Archange déjà cité dans la
Bible comme étant le malakim qui
apparaît à la Vierge Marie est un
militaire de haute hiérarchie portant
les ordres des
[Musique]
Élohims pendant 23 ans Gabriel transmet
à mahomé la Parole du Dieu Allah et la
transcription de ses parole constitue le
Coran le livre sacré des
musulmans
[Musique]
mahomé se présente aux Hébreux comme
étant définitivement le dernier prophète
mais il se moque de
lui alors mahomé arme ses fidèles combat
les Hébreux et change la direction de la
prière de Jérusalem vers la
[Musique]
M
et chef militaire mahomé fonde l'islam
un monothéisme fondamentaliste dans
lequel il n'est pas besoin de croire
pour constater l'existence d'Allah
l'Unique Dieu
[Musique]
créateurère reconnaissant un unique Dieu
créateur apparaît en Inde où le gourou
Nanak fonde le chikisme une religion
prêchant la gentillesse et la
[Musique]
prière en Europe la Révolution française
et le mouvement des lumière remettent en
question la
religion
l'idée que les théologiens peuvent
affirmer ce qu'ils veulent sans le
prouver est totalement irrecevable pour
les scientifiques qui eux doivent
toujours prouver ce qu'ils
[Musique]
affirment l'histoire des religions
devient alors une discipline
scientifique à part entière et les
gouvernements occidentaux se libèrent du
clergé et deviennent
Laï
mais le besoin de foi de l'humanité
persiste et elle s'adapte en remplaçant
le dieu surnaturel par un dieu
matériel ce nouveau dieu est l'argent et
sa religion prêche la richesse obtenue
par la
[Musique]
dette
bellique le dieu argent déclare la
guerre sainte au christianisme à l'Islam
et à tout ce qui n'est pas en
vente de même que Yahé argent arme des
mercenaires sans foi ni patrie leur
faisant massacrer des millions
d'innocents au nom du
[Musique]
marché au lieu de sir contre le
fondamentalisme économique les religions
du monde assimilent ce nouveau culte
accélérant ainsi leur propre
[Musique]
fin et l'histoire n'est pas terminée car
le dieu argent génère d'autres
[Musique]
dieux le tout dernier est te le dieu de
la
technologie
les prêtres sont un petit groupe de
jeunes milliardaires installés dans la
silicone vallée dont l'ambition est de
soumettre à leur croyan le monde le
contrôlant par
[Musique]
l'informatique Tech est adoré surtout
par les jeunes mais sa religion prêche
l'intelligence
artificielle les imprimantes
3D et la réalité
virtuelle réduisant le nombre des
emplois et poussant à la misère des
millions de
[Musique]
travailleurs les milliardaires de la
silicone valallleée eux s'enrichissent
toujours plus en vendant du
[Musique]
superflux tout comme le catholicisme qui
s'est enrichi en en dépouillant le monde
et en vendant d'illusoires images
[Musique]
pieuses tout comme l'islam qui
s'enrichit grâce au pétrole s nuisible à
la planète et qui avec cet argent arme
le
terrorisme tout comme l'hindouisme qui
divise ses fidèles en castes et laisse
mourir de fa les plus
pauvres et tout comme l'hébraïsme
depuis les temps de Jacob exproprie
encore ses voisins à coup de
[Musique]
canon c'est l'histoire de notre passé et
de notre présent qui vient de vous être
raconté c'est aussi l'histoire des
religions et que les dieux existent ou
pas c'est en leur nom que les crédules
massacrent d'autres crédules en croyant
qu'il est juste de le
[Musique]
faire un jour peut-être la connaissance
triomphratelle de cette ignorance s
prisé par les dieux et les
[Musique]
prêtres alors nous serons si évolués que
nous pourrons jouer et faire l'amour
tous les jours comme au beau vieux temps
quand nous étions de très simples
singes